you know the grasshopper walk into barge
I like that job huh you know that joke
no you know this joke um I don't know
grasshop rocks in the bar Partners goes
hey we have a drink name after you
grasshopper says you have a drink named
Steve
that's good it's a good one dude Street
jokes I love don't you love Street jokes
I do they're so fun yeah yeah they're so
simple and so easy there's nothing to
them yeah they don't mean anything a gay
couple are living together here we go
[Laughter]
and this is not that funny in sin by the
way go ahead so um they're living
together they're love they love it right
and um one guy you know he's a
stay-at-home husband and the other guy
works you know what I mean and one
morning uh the businessman that's in the
relationship gets up to go to work and
he sees his partner jerking off into a
condom
into a condom yeah into economy goes
what are you doing man he goes I'm just
packing your lunch
[Laughter]
that's a great joke